good morning everyone morning you're
late
all right five five pounds all right
we've got one of these little batteries
itty-bitty battery your engineers you're
supposed to have one at all times on you
come to the package yeah I could use a
clicker thank you so sorry I'm noticing
only now this is not working actually
the laser does work so if I put in my
eye probably is gonna hurt it
Thank You Hubert thanks all right I got
it from here yeah ladies you want Eliza
no thanks of course
terrific good morning my name is Andre
and I'm seeing a couple of familiar
faces in a few who might not have seen
before
who'd seen me before like talking the
two familiar faces yes thank you
so my name is Andre I'm good I'm going
to talk about fast wear which is the
token efficiency in the systems level
languages I've had a great time getting
here I hope you had an easier time it
was 2 hours 35 to fly from Bucharest to
London and 12:35 to get from the airport
to here so that was pretty awesome
and then I'm not wearing my badge so the
security guard is like what you do to
work here I was like I don't work I
mostly talk and that didn't help either
ok I figure out of the following one
fact which is I have too many things to
say so I'm going to this I'm never done
it before and let me tell you the way I
imagined it the way I imagined it was
like there's like 500 people here and I
would say choose your own adventure and
I would give you the choices and you'd
vote by means of applause but given that
there's like you know 30 of us here
primary we're going to do kind of a
raise of hands kind of saying all right
so we have two choices I'm not kidding
you choose so choice number one is down
to earth discussion and we're going to
discuss a few close to silicon
optimizations
strength reduction which is a
traditional compare optimization but in
fact it can be done to redesign
algorithms improve instruction level
parallelism of code discuss a bit of the
irishman arithmetic underpinnings of
optimization so what are the links in
between the sort of the tricks that we
can do in optimization there in the
actual fundaments of math that make them
possible we again we get to rethink a
few simple algorithms such as converting
integers to strings in lub and back and
we're going to show quite a bit of code
and measurements so the disadvantages
would be the fairly low level
talk some of this advice I'm giving may
not age very well with improvements in
compiler and CPU technology and the
standard of codes which not necessarily
everybody likes or as a second choice
new research and going to this would be
a more research kind of topic which
focused on two core computer science
algorithms there's only maybe a few
dozen essential algorithms in computer
science of which to our petition Tony
Hoare partition which actually veidt's
an array into in two halves one is that
it's smaller than an element and there
is larger than the given element and
quickselect which is how to find the
answer element the smallest element in
an array so that talk would focus on
these two algorithms or by means of
sentinels in unexpected places which is
kind of an interesting topic I'm going
to discuss layout in iteration strategy
and I'm going to show significant new
results academically speaking in an area
considered closed because partition and
quickselect are literally older than all
of us in this room except me no need not
even 69 so these are like 61 65 and ever
since then have been considered the
optimum nobody worked on improving them
anymore so we're going to shown your
results here on the downside this is a
complex topic if you've never heard of
partitioning quickselect before it's
unlikely this talk is going to cause you
a lot of joy and happiness it's
difficult to appreciate without set
background and it doesn't translate to
obvious practical advice for your own
work that you can take tomorrow it is
however a nice sort of researchy topic
so now by means of by means of a show of
hands please vote for this all right
vote for this
right well I gotta tell you the
following both are interesting so we
chose this right the dangerous and I
gotta tell you I've done a bit of branch
prediction here because the following
slides are going to be this so otherwise
I would have to change the slide set and
that would kill the peg guys so nice
let's talk about strength reduction so
stress reduction is a tradition a
compiler optimization so it means reduce
try to replace in any algorithm stronger
operations with you know not so strong
operations for example the classic like
when when you're kind of you know 50
year old guy coworker who thinks is
great talks about strength reduction
they say oh you should replace that
thing with that thing like the division
by two it's a shift and I'm awesome
right it's not that awesome because
compiler start doing this since 1980
last time he looked problem right so
this is sort of a classic example of
strength reduction but I wouldn't
recommend you sit down and do it because
you actually open yourself to liability
such as if you know is on sign and one
is signed one is obviously signed then
you're unclear on the side - or the
result depending on the size of the
operator center type and everything
whereas the division always gets it gets
it right so um but this is the this is
the idea of strengths reduction you want
to replace the stronger operations with
simpler operations and let me give you
sort of the Harkey of speech here we
have comparisons that would be the
cheapest I'm saying comparison without
the jump which you know a equals beam
less than T a gets B less and C that's
possible and it's actually the fastest
so less than a cycle you can think of it
then comes integral add subtract beat
operations and shift or each of which
takes one cycle like is the absolute
awesome awesome
you know most awesome thing you can
think of is one cycle to do 64-bit
edition which is quite the feat
if you think of it like adding to 64-bit
numbers kind of see now it's kind of all
the carry and you know that stuff is not
easy and to wit in 2004 that was a paper
it was the topic of a paper on hardware
how to do 64-bit edition in one cycle
and not everybody does it so right now
you can think whenever you need you have
an addition to do we can think it's
going to take one cycle you know this
less than one nanosecond so that's
pretty awesome then kind of faster
stronger operator we're kind of getting
from weakest to strongest so then comes
floating point add and subtract and
those are a separate unit all together
so the the floating point is its own
hardware what follows after that is
multiplication of integrals and floating
point so that's more costly stronger and
then goes the floating point division
remainder there is a such a thing as a
floating point remainder did you know
about this chance they take in a folder
like I gotta show this on Twitter right
now and the most expensive thing the
operated primitive operation in a CPU is
actually integral division by far it's
like we're looking at a big margin
between the last one and everything else
now you know this is kind of weird
because consider this integral division
takes more time than floating point
division which is kind of you know real
numbers I mean come on so there's got to
be an explanation for that and for this
I'm going to open to the floor so please
let me know what why do you think
integral division takes more time than
floating point division
you
all right I'll give you a hint I'll
consider this they told me they told me
not to ever do this but I'm going to
kind of walk a bit here at my own peril
so floating point division is faster
than interval division and let's think
of the floating-point number format so
64-bit floating-point vs. 64-bit integer
in a 64-bit floating-point what do we
find how is it laid out how is it
structured well floating point command
Monte's yes yes thank you so there's an
exponent and there's a mantissa the
exponent is like I think was that 11
bits 53 yeah 10 bits 1 bit for sine 10
bits for exponent and then 53 bits for
the mantissa and the actual number
you're looking for is the mantissa times
2 to the power of X 1 minus some
constant so that's a floating-point
number for you right so it's stored in
that it just so happens as the weight
stored now consider so the number is
actually you know some you know 53 bit
number times 2 to the power of whatever
right okay now I have two numbers in
this format and I want to divide them so
at this point you got a desperately
reach for that high school-level algebra
that you you know you forgot most about
and when it divides you know a to the
power of B to the a to the power of C
what do you get
you subtract the exponents thank you so
it's actually when you when it divided
two floating point numbers it turns out
you need to the much simpler operation
which is divide 253 bit numbers and also
take the difference of 210 bit numbers
so the floating point format is already
rigged to favor fast multiplication and
division which is pretty awesome I mean
how can I it's amazing they thought of
that right this is really cool in
contrast integral division not only has
64 bit of kind of payload to deal with
it also needs to get to the ultimate
precision if you can can get an
approximate result when you divide two
integers right I gotta get to the whole
nine yards there to get like the
ultimate bit so um on a more
philosophical note I don't agree with
division in principle I don't like
division it's unnatural I mean in nature
only division by two occurs but there's
no natural phenomenon that is going to
divide by 17 there's no there's nothing
in this world that naturally is going to
be our assurance this is division by 17
in contrast a lot of other sort of these
arithmetic operations do occur in that
in nature all right so in our philosophy
for the day I'm getting the wrong all
right so by means of an example let us
discuss strength reduction on a simple
function which goes the following way I
want to count the number of digits in a
number what could be simpler and it's
kind of a very nice interview question
or very nicely a question for those of
you have like kids aged like 6 to 10
like you know write a JavaScript little
program you know Johnny to you know
figure out how many digits are in a
number and the way the natural
implementation would go is on gaining a
loop to increment the running result and
dividing the number right 10 until I ran
out of digits and as the
wait works right alright so now the
problem with this guy is of course it's
going to use a bunch of divisions
so once optimize this right so want to
make this as fast as possible and
actually there's a reason for it even
though it doesn't look at terribly
useful function it actually is so let's
make this a lot faster by of presumably
reducing the strength of this division
here however it's actually a
multiplication because there's a paper I
think in the nineties that showed how
division by a constant can be translated
with multiplication into multiplication
by different weird very large constant
with overflow followed by six upper
shift or an add to width
let me actually show you and I'm going
to take advantage of the very nice tech
guys who let me switch slide here which
is a non-trivial thing okay so let's do
this I'm going to change an example here
you should all use this slide GCC
Godbole dot org it allows you to type
code in C++ and see that this assembly
in real time alright so let's actually
say our returning by 10 and you don't
need to know assembler to make kind of
very interesting draw very interesting
conclusions from from this take a look
at the directed assembly so you're going
to see that we have this weird negative
constant being multiplied mu Allah is
like multiply I don't have to have a PhD
for this kind of stuff right you don't
need to so it's multiply and that kind
of stuffs and it's going to be followed
by a shift which is the fix up so very
interestingly we translated the division
by ten into multiplication which is
already the compiler at work doing
strength reduction for you
and that's pretty awesome because
there's a lot of work here behind the
scenes here that's happening terrific
very nice all right sorry
so let's make this faster ideas I'm
opening this to the so I'm opening the
room here ideas to make this faster get
rid of multiplications if you can sorry
use the lookup table
excellent idea actually we're going to
kind of it's a good option to explore
use a lookup table how big would the
table be it would be fairly large so
unless we kind of find a way to carve
the space better we would need to to
have a very large table or kind of make
sure we use a table for only like
subsets of these digits um what are yes
yes
the binary search on the number
excellent so actually kind of take the
like the middle bits like 32 that kind
of stuff actually that's a very good
idea but it runs a bit of fall of the
law of small numbers oh I didn't mention
that it's all part of a play I paid that
guy so so the point the point is the law
of small numbers is this most numbers in
a program small right there's a lot of
big numbers which is completely
different statistics so the law small
number says in most programs you're
dealing with like numbers with you like
1 and 100 and that's the most are 0 like
90% are 0 and 90% of all strings are
empty
so that's your baseline and then you
have a few small numbers then you have
very few very large numbers so that
binary search is going to assume that
you're the most likely thing you're
looking for is a number that's in the
billions which is unlikely right so
although it's a great data so it's a
great idea to to get us excited here
other ideas and I kind of destroyed the
I destroyed the mood here yes huh a bias
kind of ok all right so that kind of
gets us to
the following point and here I have a
few things to say about this function
number one it features an infinite loop
and ostensibly infinite loop like this
right
semicolon sells for like forever all
right
and let me pause it the following you
want to write fast code you always have
to start with an infinite loop like the
first is I want to make this function
fast the first thing you write is this
forever
I know it's paradoxical because infinite
loops take a very long time right
but actually they it's a an infinite
loop goes like this it's the least is
the least work to loop right because the
jump at the beginning of the loop it
does not no work there I've been working
Facebook for most six years and I've
interviewed hundreds literally hundreds
of people
so I've held like the record of like the
most whatever the guy who interview the
most people at Facebook for a while so
that was because I kind of was at these
events hiring events and university and
whatnot so I would ask people please
implement for me HDR HDR brute force but
just don't do any unnecessary work if he
writes ER find the substring in a string
right it's a C function what could be
easier further like it's amazing like
you look at the social phenomena
underlying this question so far like 20%
of the people can't get it working
programmers so 20% cannot get it off the
ground cannot implement it on the
interview pressure to start with which I
found amazing it's very interesting it
tells you that you know interview
pressure is huge and also that you know
for another experience program is
difficult to kind of get this rolling
um the second thing is a lot of people
would start with a structure loop there
is a for I equals 0 I less than oh wait
a second Oh ACR Leno's no no that's not
going to get you there right because
it's quadratic it's going to evaluate a
ctrl n every time right so then other
you know they're off so as soon as I
pointed I thought they would see Oh
feisty any
SGR Lenin and they would iterate
themselves and the problem there that
was in a CSTR if you start with a
structure loop like a classic for loop
with you know initialization condition
increment it's just not going to work
this good you're going to do a lot of
unnecessary work so I would say if you
want to write fast code start with that
forever and then if you get to the
structure loop so you know naturally you
can rewrite it but don't start with a
structure loop because it sets up your
mind the wrong way to wit this cannot be
structured in into a classic for loop
and the way it works is the following
love being a lot of small numbers if the
value is less than 10 then I know what
to do I'm just returning result and done
and then 100 1000 and 10,000 and I'm
going to do an addition remember one
cycle each addition here is one cycle
and then if I got to something greater
than 10,000 I'm going to reset my
calculation by four digits at a time by
dividing by 10,000 and then I'm going to
add four to the result and continue so
what is this is not enrolling because
many people look at this and say oh this
is unrolling of course it's a classic no
it's not unrolling because unrolling is
you do the same thing many times in this
is sort of it's just different it looks
like it so what what is the strength
reduction we've done here
what did we get rid of and what did we
yes right so we have we have more
comparisons and we have a few more
additions right but we do 4x fewer
divisions right which is often and for
small numbers are in really good shape
by the way another mistake that this
code has just kind of static look at it
you can tell it's inefficient by this
zero here it is there's no number that
has zero digits so starting at zero is
already a loss it's you're wasting time
you should start someone like the
absolute minimum digits a number can
have it should be one right so already
I'm kind of doing a zero and then I'm
incrementing like an idiot and it's just
a mess right in contrast this is like
clearly just goes the minimum Road to
whatever it needs to be great how much
faster do you think this is going to be
how did you make for me who gives me
like I don't know five percent or or
more five percent raise your hands five
percent or more more okay Oh 20 percent
or more will give me 20 percent 50
percent one 1/2 speed improvement or
more one and a half 1.5 X a few hands
all right thank you have a you know an
auction here right I should have that
the fast talk of auctioneers in America
right actually it's a lot better than
that we look at an improvement between
two and six times in speed so it's
staggering and by the way um about this
drop here how we can explain it for us
there's a drop here there's a drop here
and there's a drop here sorry yes it's
exactly where we take the toll of a
division this is we doing the division
here we go the one here one here so it's
exactly the you know eight to nine
digits and twelve to thirteen and that
kind of stuff why is he not happening as
for excellent question I don't know
I'm not kidding so if we look at this
for for a long time trying to identify
the pattern here at the beginning and I
can't apparently that you know sort of
other noises in the in the cost of the
function are influencing this to the
extent you don't see the cost of that
the price of the first division but it's
a very pertinent thing to ask yourself
about right awesome so well we have like
a very nice going here on a useless
function that's terrific and very
pleased by that we improve to up towards
ooh a function that nobody has a use for
however we're going to see soon that
it's usable within another context and
I'm going to talk about minimization of
indirect rights indirect rights are
right through a pointer like you have
like an array element and you right
through the index of the array so it's
not like a right to local variable with
a name like a equals 5 or a plus plus or
whatever so that's not an indirect right
that's a sort of a direct right the
indirect rights are your enemy you
should be very very very very kind of
parsimonious about giving away you
shouldn't give them away right why
because indirect rights are next to
impossible to put a register and
registering means the compiler takes
automatically for your sinks and put
them in registers like things like
values variables names and put them in
registers and it all goes amazingly well
another thing that is kind of solid at
the right an indirect right is really a
read and a write whenever you write
something you actually do two things you
do a read and then I write who knows why
yes Cubert cache line more explanation
please
that's right thank you
so all transfers in memory do not occur
at word size level people I you know
like people who are not kind of hardware
sort of I don't know savvy tend to think
that all transfers occur at like it's a
64-bit machine 64-bit transfers from you
know words between memory and the
Machine yes it's actually not 64-bit
it's 64 bytes so they're right about one
thing the number is the same it's just
different you need to measure that was a
joke just I'm going to raise my hands
whenever I make one so this you know so
just laugh everything you know this
should be a guy with a notes laugh so
actually whenever you want to write a
word like eight sorry 64 bits like it
you know like four bytes or eight bytes
it's you know what would you do as an
engineer if you could only read and
write 64 bytes at a time you read the
whole goddamn thing you write the little
one thing and they write the whole
goddamn thing back and that's the way it
works so read is actually of write is
actually read followed by right there's
no instruction in the Intel set that
tells you please write me the whole
cache line right now I've looked for a
way for a while I couldn't find it there
are some other architectures that do
allow it and those experienced like 2x
faster writes because you don't need to
read any more and he makes a cache study
the problem
make it a cache dirty after right is
that you know cash you need you need to
kind of replace all pages with new pages
in caches like classic cache
architecture
whenever the cache is dirty you need to
write back the cache that particular
cache line into memory if it's dirty if
it's not that you just throw it away so
it's better to not dirty the cache so
all right um I see how to apply this
awesome piece of knowledge here so we're
going to implement the you 64 to asking
and our baseline looks like the
following we have a value and we want to
deposit the value at some
address in form of ASCII characters so
does the you know integral to ASCII
conversion
it's a classic routine and if you crack
up on any library or any book on how to
do these things you're going to see that
the way it works is called horner scheme
the algorithm and it goes well I'm going
to deposit the number starting from the
least significant digit which is ASCII 0
plus the remainder of dividing value by
10 and that's my last digit this is my
last digit here value divided by 10
sorry that value remainder 10 is my
least significant digit and in order to
bring him into the ASCII realm I'm going
to add ASCII 0 to it and if it's 0 I get
asked is 0 and if it's not I get asked
in 9 is right this is obvious right okay
great just not for me please smile and
nod okay awesome and then I'm going to
make progress by dividing the value by
10 and therefore I'm going to get and
the next the next digit and I do this in
a loop until I run out of value the
problem with the scheme is that I'm
obtaining the number in reverse form I'm
getting the last significant reason
ISKCON digits first and I'm getting a
most significant digit last which is
terrible because then I need to reverse
that the whole thing yes so that's what
I'm doing this little fix-up loop here
which is I'm going to swap I'm going to
reverse this will be like a CD reverse
star destination so I'm just explicit
ating the loop here to make it clear
that this is going on question for
everybody how do we improve this
function how do we make it faster yes
measure the number that's what we need
because right now we're discovering the
number of digits simultaneously with
actually writing them so one one
approach that was suggested what how
about we figure out how many digits
there are and then we know how many
digits we need to write and we write
them backwards in the first place all
right well amazing you actually have a
function that does that in it
remember digits an
all right so here you got to understand
this is unclear that it's going to make
things any better because it's a gambit
we're going through the number twice
we're doing twice as many kind of
primitive operations with the number but
we're taking that risk because we just
said minimize or that minimizing
Arkwright's and these are all all that
loop at the end of the function is
indirect twice it's rights to the
pointers
so the gambit is I'm going to do more
calculations by looking at the number
twice but I'm going to save on the on
these all of the speed fixed up loop I'm
going to throw away all right awesome so
great great the first line in the new
function is digits 10 yay so we got to
use it it's not useless and we're going
to say Auto comes result gets digits 10
and then I'm going to position myself at
the result minus 1 which is the position
of the last digit and I'm going to write
a buffers position and decrement
positions I'm going to write the number
backwards in the first place and when
I'm done I'm done
even better remember the law of big
numbers the law small numbers while V
greater than or equal to 10 because if I
have a number that's only one digit I
can do it a lot simpler look at the last
two lines of that thing I'm just going
to catch the last digit too you ain't
and a desk easier to it and that's my
last digit and if you just so happens I
have a small number that I'm not going
to go through that whole loop at all I'm
just going to go through the very end
make sense yes all right it's not very
complicated
awesome so well my question to you is
like is this faster how much how many
percentage percentage points are going
to give me if this is actually it's not
a it's a function that is actually
useful it's a library function that is
can be actually very intensively used in
things like that databases that only
work with the ASCII transfers and
there's a bunch of web frameworks that
only work with as
we transport a lot of numbers across
these interfaces you're going to have to
do a lot of that you have to do a lot of
conversion to ASCII and a lot of
conversion from ASCII to wit at the hive
database which is a very large-scale
database used at Facebook they had this
problem which was all transfers occurred
in ASCII format and whenever you read a
bunch of data you'd have to go through
this and back a lot of times and it
would be like you know 20% of the whole
run time of an interesting application
just the conversion which is amazing
anyhow getting back here what what is
the improvement you're looking at we're
looking at here I look at I don't know
25 percent anyone or more everyone's
like fool me once huh all right so not a
lot of you are like believers here let
me kind of tell you what I believe the
the sources of possible improvements are
your indirect right regular access
patterns are going to go through memory
just once backwards and that means
prefetching and good things fast on
small numbers and data dependencies are
reduced you're late all right you're not
missing out I said nothing interesting
so far we're looking at an amazing like
two-plus improvement on small numbers up
to like 114 or 20% improvement for very
large numbers on a function that was
considered at its optimum like if you
crack up on GCC or Visual Studio is
implementation of this primitive you're
going to see that everybody does it the
first way or baseline nobody does it
this way and the fact that we apply two
simple principles strength reduction
minimize indirect writes to completely
redesign and rethink an algorithm that
was considered unimprovable this should
get you very excited so this is why
you're here presumably
so look at a very instant improvement
which can actually make a difference in
the bottom line of an intensive
application
so switching gears a bit right now I'm
going to talk about the topic that is
very dear to me which I call the
Forgotten parallelism because it's a
very hot topic right now pair
programming and all that and there is
something that we tend to forget it
exists to wit let me um bring up the can
anyone see this like I'm thinking like
the distance to the projector and you
know the resolution here thanks for
taking that food is not going to help so
does anyone see the letters alright if
you see the letters you're tailgating
right so um it's a cpu and the weight
works is the data flows top to bottom
this is traditional CPU you know kind of
diagrams and we look at the lifetime of
an instruction ship which is like you
know the reddish stuff is sort of the
brief edge buffer and you know the
instruction decoder and stuff the
instructions go there's a childhood and
then I get to the the adolescence which
is they're going to have sort of a
register location and there's going to
be some more slicing and dicing but what
I'm trying to get here is where the
action happens which is the ALU the
arithmetic logic unit which contains and
this is sort of you don't need to see
the letters to figure this out there's a
lot of stuff going on in parallel there
are a lot of things that have like
arrows flowing into them and out of them
but they are horizontally scaled the XK
like this and you know presumably I get
to kind of feed them all at once if I
kind of organize my ducks in a row right
and then I have like sort of the memory
order buffer to kind of rearrange
properly the rights and stuff and hear
them the data goes out from the
execution the instructions get retired
and it's all good and then we have on
the side caches and whatnot so the
interesting thing is here that this is
just one core is not on CPU and you have
like several of those literally in your
pocket
in your pocket in our laptop on a
desktop machine on your blades in the
data center and if you don't light these
up if you don't get to use these they
remain unlit forever no many no matter
how many of these you have no matter how
much you scale in the traditional
parallelism sense if you don't get to
use these they remain unused then you're
wasting actually you're wasting hardware
and actually wasting power as well
because I gotta tell you even though
they're not used they still need to be
clocked so they're gonna like clock
accounts for like thirty percent of the
circuitry and the power in a CPU so
you're gonna a lot there's a bunch of
stuff going on and essentially you know
if they stay dark there's no way you can
recover that parallelism that you lost
so okay let me actually read to you what
this is stored data age you store
addressing unit this is for address
computation integer a branch unit add
and move SSE integer floating point add
floating point add sec add floating
point multiplication multiplication
multiplication and division so you have
all of these things that could actually
happen simultaneously and the question
is now like for us as engineers like I
don't know the instructions that take me
to that beautiful world inside the core
and I have no idea what the simple I
need to use to get to light those up and
you know yeah I know the constant it
sounds very fun and but you know what
can I do here I'm no I plus plus okay
what what happens here what happens if I
say apply plus equal to you know etc so
what how are these instructions going to
translate into lighting these are these
awesome units up well actually there is
a way
um this is it this is the secret to
everything if you want better
instruction level parallelism all we
have to do at the source code level is
have fewer data dependencies which means
we get to define those first what are
data dependencies what is the data
dependency it simply means the the start
of an operation depends on the result of
an operation preceding it that means
this particular operation is dependent
upon the previous operation and we want
to make as few of those as possible
humanly possible so you want to minimize
data dependencies and my favorite method
of teaching is by means of examples so
let's actually do the opposite function
ask you to integer and the way it goes
is I'm going to add that enforces like
an assert you can think of it is going
to throw an exception if the condition
is not true so I'm validating that by
getting the right pointer CTL style
begin and end and I want to convert that
particular string into into a number
awesome so that I'm going to start with
a result and again if you look at any
book they're going to do the following
way result gets result times 10 plus the
current digit and I'm going to increase
the result by you know going through the
digits from most significant to the
least significant and at the end I'm
going to get the actual number and
there's that enforce there inside the
loop it's kind of verifying that I'm
getting only digits and not something
else
all right following is just sort of a
classic right so I'm sure any of us
could sit down and we actually write
this down and it works it's a classic
it's a classic approach and of course
it's suboptimal that's the theme of the
day right it's about people I hate it
it's terrible actually I'm going to
prove by the end of this talk you're
going to hate this you're going to you
can have a physical aversion toward the
function because I'm going to have you
look at the underlying mass that's
happening inside the function and when
you write it in mass format it just
looks awful
I first like consider this right off the
bat I'm multiplying by zero like an
idiot there zero times ten plus five
that's my most significant digit
everything times 10 plus 2 which is the
second digit right everything times 10
plus 3 which is the third digit
everything multiplied by 10 because I'm
you know kind of you know my making
progress with my digit here plus mine
everything times and I don't I don't
have a heart attack right now so I'm not
going to continue but in essence what
I'm saying here is that we're forcing a
look at the process it looks ugly on the
page you can't format it right and
that's not because I practice our
finding list the only place or price is
great it's in list because at least they
have a different meaning they make it
one dimensional structure represent the
two dimensional tree so it's completely
different in mass what do parentheses do
what is the purpose of you inserting a
parenthesis in math you force the order
of operation to something that's not
natural because if it were natural you
wouldn't need parentheses so or in you
know prophecies are actually
dependencies because it means I need to
do this before I do anything else so
essentially like everything depends on
just instead before in this approach and
you can see by showing the arithmetic
behind the computation and this looks
ugly
right so you know one of my goals in
briefing in this was you know I want to
get rid of the prints you know I want to
make it beautiful and beautiful is going
to make it fast right so you know
there's a number of lines of thinking I
took and one was how about some divide
and conquer thing like a binary search
like I'm going to divide the string into
two sections and that was kind of an
interesting start I kind of saw oh yeah
so we have like this number is like 5 to
3 times 1000 plus 9 to 4 so that gives
me the following thought how about this
representation and how what about the
eye implant an algorithm that's going to
do this instead of that right oh this is
beautiful because it has no parents and
it's actually 4 you can format it nicely
it does look beautiful right and it does
no in unnecessary operation there's no 4
times 1 or there's no time 0 anything
it's not it's you know it's just a
minimum amount of work that gets you
there you can see the number here on
vertical is the same number is there and
you have a number of constants multiples
of 10 and therefore let us actually
implement this guy which has much fewer
data dependencies actually ok let me Oh
let me show you the code first so I'm
going to write like a very large library
logic you know 20 powers of 10 it's
something I'm very good at writing like
large number of zeros is very after that
so you know and it's going to be a
triangle right because going to be like
that large number followed by numbers 4
by 1 0 and so on up until like the power
of 0 which is 1 and then I'm going to go
through the this particular array of
constants this don't kind of don't hold
it against me just kind of the length of
the array so that we like 20 there it's
like 20 minus C minus B what is this I
doing what is it putting me placing in
the array
it's placing me exactly at the position
of the most significant digit in this
particular example here is going to
position me at 100,000
so it's positioning me at the right
point for the most significant digit in
the array and that's my starting point
for iteration and then I'm going to
iterate from there incrementing I so
this this particular arm function
implements the underlying math that is
simpler and again the question for is is
this going to be faster and if so is it
going to be significantly faster because
we're interested in significant results
here I think it's going to be better I
wouldn't waste your time right so let's
look at the results whoa awesome like
3.3 X improvements for this you're kind
of one digit and then it kind of decays
to 2x so you got the two x is 100%
improvement again a function that was
considered unimprovable I hope this is
good the stylet is not awkward I hope
it's a sensor
yeah that's kind of a cool thing yes yes
and you know all that thinking is going
on right now in your minds prince is
like oh my god I can't believe I'm
sitting here it's like when it's like
that break so three point times two two
point X and nice enough like the most
improvements are for small numbers which
is what I care about
let's be awesome great so don't forget
this associative means paralyzed about
to give something associative going the
CPU knows it's associative everybody
knows I need the whole the whole you
know arithmetic in the comparing the CP
are rigged towards they know addition is
associative right so they can do it in
any order so that's reason we got a
great improvement at high level by sorry
at low level by using a very high level
approach there's no assembly here I mean
we don't need to do anything clever you
don't need to say oh there's this
instruction do you know about you know
it should use the secret instruction are
nobody knows about and now you just use
simple principles to get you there all
right so let's actually make you see
that red line and force the verification
that I'm getting the the right thing so
let's make that guys
because everything that's in a loop is
going to count a lot so how do we make
this verification faster
what is boiling down to what this is
boiling down to is if start be less than
zero or start be greater than nine then
you know it's kind of it's an incorrect
input otherwise I'm going to continue
with the computation this is the core of
my loop make it faster make that test
faster make that test faster
knotti not too much blood in the
caffeine right so well you know it's I'm
not doing this real-time so I've been
thinking of this and the way I thought
of this first was you know that or the
double or means you try the for the left
hand first and if it's true you're done
if it's false you try the the second
right that's the short circuit
evaluation in C++ we all know in love
but it's actually it imposes a data
dependency so actually it's faster to
did this way with a pipe with the
bitwise or because then you can run both
in parallel yes it's semantically the
same thing it's just getting there
faster so I tried this in GCC and guess
what happened which do you think is
faster this guy or that guy genius
they're exactly the same so GCC was way
ahead of me there has icons one must be
smart I use a pipe and this is like yeah
I'm there buddy so no problem there yeah
so GCC actually generating this code
from that source so even though I
specified the short circuit and whatever
GCC figured that the these tube can be
valid in parallel doesn't affect the
semantics of the program it could if I
like a function call here that would be
influenced but that would influence this
result but you know in this case it's
simple enough that the compiler just
figured out it generated this so that
but then you know I'm a human I'm not a
comparison I can be clever I can use a
table driven approach by means of each
digit is digit is actually a large table
and gets you there in like constant time
all right so which which do you think is
faster is digit or this guy well I mean
these guys are equivalent how about is
digit is digit faster table-driven
well actually I was amazed GCT drink to
the sinkhole for his digit right here so
you kind of look through it and said oh
is digit I know what you're doing buddy
I know what you're doing there so I'm
going to just direct optimal code for
even though you're an idiot because this
digit is actually doing a short testing
4-1 and whatnot so it's not optimal all
right so I kind of gave up give up on
that line of reasoning but I'm still
bothered by the two tests here I need to
test the same thing twice against during
against nine so what I did was I used
our sign wrapper rule this is a
scientific term you may not have heard
of which is unsigned you know just goes
away like if you take a subtraction of
transline numbers you can become a very
large unsigned number right it's like 1
minus 2 it becomes like the maximum
unsigned so I did this I took well let
me take the unsigned of star b minus 0
and i know if that is greater than 10 is
out of range it's not good because it's
either number that's below 0 or above 9
so then i replace this thing with one
test and even better i got to reuse that
thing you CD because I need to the
difference anyway so I got to reuse the
same computation twice but now there's a
profound reason for which this whole
unsigned replacement worked because you
know it's you've got to think of it like
it's possible that I have like I take
the difference of Transplant numbers and
you know I have the wrapper rule going
on but I still kind of get into the
right range by mistake
what how can you explain that I'm not
gonna reach the right result by mistake
well yes Shawn you're not going to rub
that far yes so that's sort of the
intuition exactly so you're not going to
wrap that fine
you know how exactly do you prove
mathematically that you're not going to
wrap that far and actually the way it
goes is the following subtracting with
with wrap around like modular
subtraction is an injective function at
this point everyone's like okay at this
point you lost me here is talking
vaccines what's going on here
an injective function is a function that
map's different values to different
values it is never going to map
different values to the same value and
it turns out that the mod does the
subtraction in modulus arithmetic has
this particular property which means
it's always going to take the you know
two different input two different inputs
two different outputs which means is
never going to go to the right result by
mistake so we have this very interesting
kind of principle in basic modular
arithmetic which take us to a takes us
to optimization because I save the
comparison and subtraction there which
is awesome so it's not tricks we're
doing here with doing basic math and to
wit actually it is measurable and be
significant they're like ILP is our
previous the violating and the green
thing is the unsigned reprove which
becomes significant for larger numbers
and - it actually plotted this against
several functions several baselines so
on the horizontal axis at one I have my
baseline which is the built-in library
function a to you well and then we have
that yellow thing is a sort of a
handwritten function that does sort of
our baseline that we we showed and then
we have the help Ian we have a
two-year-old and I T plus one sign is
the best is the fastest compared to the
- a - ul and what do you think this red
thing is like five times slower than
anything else including itself what is
that guy
you can see like lexical cast that uses
a stream friends so if you know does
something really really really really
really slow do like use the sed stream I
streams because they're going to like
super slow um it's actually fast if you
see down and in with pen and paper it's
gonna be faster so terrible right that's
another joke right there was a guy with
a joke banner there alright so we have
like very good improvements on classic
algorithms and now we're going to apply
one of the classical optimizations which
is loop unrolling thank you loop
unrolling with loop unrolling we are
going to simply duplicate the whole
thing as the body of the loop several
times and then we're going to add
everything at the bottom and that is a
sort of a very well-known optimization
technique and guess what it helps boom
especially for large waves and you see
kind of the the ripples they are
depending on how many passes to the
Unruh robot I did so that's pretty
awesome so don't forget we talked about
strength reduction today and that's not
only a compiler optimization that
replaces the division with
multiplication or division with shift
and stuff like that it's it's a way of
thinking that allows you to rethink
algorithms that are classic into better
version of those algorithms right and
then we have we've discussed
minimization of enterprise which is a
very good technique so you know again be
extremely sparing with your rights so
give away rights like give away money
like don't spend them on like material
goods there's another joke just because
today is not going well ok we gotta get
some coffee who's going to be my second
talk right after this all right so get
some coffee ok and actually country
those who don't want to come come
because awesome now it's much better
than this so don't forget to minimize
indirect rights make sure you make as
few rights to array elements as you can
rights to name variables are very
different because those go to our rights
to registers and those have much better
efficiency profile and again don't
forget the Forgotten parallelism which
is the instruction level parallelism
that you should you should essentially
use by means of minimizing the data
dependencies in your code so now you
know I've showed you a few examples and
actually there's a library embodying
those examples
it's a facebook poly library of which I
wrote a fair fraction and you're going
to see a bunch of these in there so
there are high performance
implementations of some some classic
algorithms in there and a few data
structures so I highly recommend you
take a look at it
alright with this I'm done thank you so
much you've been awesome
thank you
[Applause]
for questions yes which tools they used
to find bottlenecks in a program going
to redirect that question to the
audience because I'm sure there are
quite a few ideas that are people are
already yes what tools are we using
alright so if I saw like this classic
profiling proof you know G profs need
sort of attune inter has another tool I
forgot the name actually I just got the
license because somebody saw my talk and
it's not do you want the free license
for the Intel tools and stuff and I said
sure it's free why not so indeed and
also that the sort of the classic sort
of your own roll around princess based
benchmarking and stuff it shouldn't be
very hard to get to the core of where
the bottlenecks are but definitely need
to measure because I've seen so many
people who optimized amazingly well
like command line processing that's
another joke so can i press these days
like literally like one microsecond out
of an hour long running program and
people are expending time on that it's
amazing and the engineers have this
spirit like in that job with the
guillotine that wasn't working everybody
would not the guillotine would be grey
she would be kind of mercied right and
the engineer who was about to be
executed by the guillotine said I think
I know the problem with that thing I can
fix it for you so you can kill me so
similarly well not similarly but you
know relatedly
we have a tendency to work on problems
that we find fun and interesting even
though they're completely irrelevant or
actually work against our our best
interest so definitely the first step is
to measure and you would find the most
surprising results while measuring I've
developed I've been working I've been at
this for a long time and the one thing I
can say that silicon is a human not a
nonhuman sorry yeah that's a record
non-human it's it's not it doesn't work
it can't develop the brain pattern
Bay star patterns detecting things and
silicon is just weird it doesn't work
that way
so intuition is not a good way to
understand performance of thoughts I
feel like the most amazing things in
what people think is fast code and like
what actually starts code it's amazing
the questions so I'm glad this
measurement point was brought up
questions come on
all right so I'll be around here during
the break and thanks again see you
around